[Musik]
let's gesehen habe ich ihnen ja im
dezember 2017 da hat er zum ersten mal
in deutschland eine chanel schau gezeigt
damals in der elbphilharmonie in hamburg
und da gab es einen ganz berührenden
moment machte schau das war nach der
show party in der fischauktionshalle und
da saß er an seinem tisch ab geschäft
natürlich von seinen bodyguards namen
lily rose und hat seine brille abgezogen
um essen zu können weil es da auch sehr
düster war und das war sehr für mich ein
sehr berührender moment weil er da auf
einmal wie nackt aus st damals habe ich
irgendwie gedacht ja auch so ein genie
wie karl lagerfeld ist natürlich
irgendwie wie sterblich ja und das war
so ein moment der war irgendwie traurig
ich mit trösten dass man gesehen hat ja
es irgendwie eigentlich aus fleisch und
blut weil er sich sonst immer so sehr
stilisiert hat er hat sich ja auch in
seinem auftreten immer ein bisschen noch
verändert im laufe der zeit als sehr
dick war
da hatte er diesen fächer den er immer
mit sich herumgetragen hat also er hat
die seine fröhlichkeit abgelenkt auf
diesen fächer und und dann später als er
plötzlich wieder ganz schmal wurde
spielte der fächer überhaupt gar keine
rolle mehr
[Musik]
das dauerte sehr lange bis er sich
sozusagen öffnete für leute aber dann
war er unglaublich toll unglaublich
zuverlässig auch sehr zugewandt und lieb
und wenn man in paris ins hotel kam
stand schon ein riesen strauß mit weißen
rosen auf dem zimmer ich habe ihn einmal
gesagt ja das hat das halbe zimmer
ausgefüllt das von der sehr lustig und
hat trotzdem weiter große straße
geschickt
[Musik]
karl lagerfeld war in den 90er jahren
noch sehr zugänglich weil er auch noch
nicht so geschwächt war weil er nicht so
alt war
und da konnte man nach den schauen sehr
leicht zu umgehen mit dem plaudern und
vor allen dingen auch dass bei ihnen
wichtig nicht über die kollektion
falsche komplimente zu machen sondern
über die politik in deutschland zu reden
oder über ein neues buch was erschienen
war denn er war ja unglaublich belesen
hat sehr viele zeitungen gelesen auch
die faz dem abonnement bekommen wenn ich
zum beispiel gesagt habe ja ich bin von
der faz an hat ja gesagt nach einfach z
das ist die beste deutsche zeitung
vermutlich hat er das allen kollegen
auch konkurrenz aber man hat sich dann
eigentlich gleich wohl gefühlt und hatte
einem noch ein bisschen die hand
getätschelt und es war eigentlich immer
sehr sehr nett mit ihm zu sprechen
[Musik]
es war überhaupt nicht schwierig ihn zu
fotografieren weil also er war einfach
eine persönlichkeit irgendwie und eine
inszenierung und und er hat
wahrscheinlich auch genau darauf
geachtet wie erscheint
[Musik]
wir haben ende 2012 darüber geredet dass
er auch gerne mal karikaturen zeichnen
würde und dann habe ich gesagt er mache
das doch für unser magazin
und er hat gesagt ja ich habe ihnen
vorgeschlagen wir nennen das ganze
karikatur und daher sofort gesagt
wunderbar war unglaublich schnell
unglaublich geistreich witzig haute ein
zitat um die ohren
ich habe nie jemanden getroffen ein
interviewpartner der so umfassend
gebildet war der so viel wusste so
schnell auch war
und da gibt es in deutschland wenige
vielleicht noch wolfgang joop oder
harald schmidt die auf diese art
antworten können denke mal es wird wenig
menschen mit diesem talent was er hatte
irgendwie geben also man diese großen
figuren die so breit humanistisch
gebildet waren und ich denke mal solche
universalgenies gibt es sowieso wenig
und in der mode da werden wir sind jetzt
eher leute gefragt die die wirklich mode
sehr sehr gut können es ist eigentlich
egal was sie sonst machen und deswegen
wird es auch schwer sein das so neue
lagerfeld in der mode sich entwickeln
können
es gibt in der mode im moment keine
klaren aussagen und keine klaren
tendenzen
es ist sehr beliebig und mit einer zur
soll einer solchen galionsfigur wie karl
lagerfeld verliert die mode noch mal ein
stück an wirklicher präsenz und
bedeutung
[Musik]